[Music]
Fox's hit musical drdy Glee made fans
laugh cry and sing along for six
award-winning Seasons but not all of the
performers who brought the show to life
are still with us today Cory Monte
played Finn Hudson an All-American jock
with a sensitive side and soothing voice
Finn's on again off again relationship
with leam Michelle's Rachel Barry was a
centerpiece of the show's dramatic
moments earning the affectionate Port
meau finchel however mon teth came to
the Glee cast with some weighty personal
struggles in a 2011 interview with
parade the Canadian actor opened up
about his battle with drugs and alcohol
which began when he was just 13 years
old by the time he was 19 Monte's
friends and family organized an
intervention after which the actor
entered rehab for the first time
unfortunately Monte's demons continued
to haunt him throughout his 20s
according to E online he entered rehab
again in 2013 completing the program at
the end of April then on July 14th news
broke that Monte was found dead in his
Vancouver hotel room autopsy results
revealed that the actor died of an
accidental overdose of hair and alcohol
with traces of Codine and morphine also
found in his blood the third episode of
the fifth season of Glee titled the
quarterback was dedicated to Monte
everyone wants to talk about how he died
too but who cares One Moment in his
whole life I care more about how he
lived every show about high school needs
a bad boy for Glee that was Mark sing's
character Noah Puck Puckerman sing
appeared in the show for the entirety of
the series though he was only a
recurring character for its final two
seasons much like Shakespeare's
character of the same name Puck was a
Mischief maker albe it a lovable one as
the series resident deviant Puck was
known for sexual exploits and violent
tendencies like his co-star Cory Monte
saling also found himself in
unflattering headlines in 2013 sing's
ex-girlfriend roxan gorill sued the
Texas native alleging he forced her to
have unprotected sex though sing denied
the accusations team Z reports he paid
gella a settlement of $2.7 million out
of court a few months after Glee ended
saling was arrested and charged with
possession of child pornography when
authorities searched his California home
they discovered more than 50,000 images
of child pornography on his computer
sing pleaded guilty in December 2017
with sentencing set for March 2018
likely facing several years in prison
saling died by suicide in January 2018
he was 35 years old Jane Lynch is one of
only five Glee actors to star in a main
role for all six seasons of the show as
Sue Sylvester head coach of William
McKinley High School's cheerleading
squad Lynch played the show's villain
typically clad and a tracksuit Sylvester
stocked the halls of McKinley instilling
fear in both students and staff despite
her edges however Sue also had a soft
spot for Becky Jackson a McKinley
student with Down Syndrome who she took
under her Wing though her affection for
Becky seems out of character viewers
eventually learned that Sue has an older
sister Jean who also has Down syndrome
there's really only one person in the
world I want to impress who who you
silly Robin Troy who came to Glee with
no acting experience played Jean
Sylvester in five episodes throughout
seasons 1 and two too traky died in 2019
from Alzheimer's disease at the age of
63 while not a star of the series Cho's
involvement with Glee helped raise
awareness for Down syndrome in a nearly
unprecedented way for the first season
of Glee Nia Rivera played the recurring
character Santana Lopez one of Sue's top
cheerleaders before being promoted to
the show's main cast in season 2 just as
Mark sing's character filled the role of
bad boy Rivera's character served as the
mean girl though that Persona softened
over time in addition to providing
powerful vocals and new directions
Santan also added to the show's LGBT
sensibilities early in the series
sintana is revealed to be bisexual and
in season 6 she marries fellow Glee Club
Alum Britney Pierce in July 2020 Rivera
took her four-year-old son on a pontoon
boat in California's Lake Peru when
Rivera failed to return the rental boat
at the appointed time a team was sent to
locate the boat and its passengers when
the boat was found only Rivera's son was
on board the child told authorities that
after a swim his mother helped him back
onto the boat before she slipped beneath
the water's surface and disappeared
after an ex exhaustive and multi-day
search the Ventura County Sheriff's
Office announced the discovery of
Rivera's body according to E online an
autopsy concluded that Rivera died as a
result of accidental drowning she was 33
years old bildz ancient librarian Jean
sincere appeared in three episodes of
Glee during its first and second Seasons
her role largely consisted of either
shushing or glaring at the Glee club
members as they broke into exuberant
songs in her Library however in season
1's bad reputation the librarian
response to Performance of You Can't
Touch This by suggesting that the club
members recreate the song for the Sunday
service at her church the role of the
ancient librarian was typical of
sincere's Television career which began
in the late 1940s and concluded in 2012
with a guest appearance on I Carly a
trained stage actress sincere made her
debut on Broadway in the 1941 production
of arsonic and Old Lace and appeared in
other shows before touring Europe as a
part of the Uso after nearly three
decades away from television sincere
returned to the small screen in a 1985
episode of Kagney and Lacy and moved
into steady work as a guest player in
series like newart Murphy Brown and
Everybody Loves Raymond she also made
occasional forray into feature film work
the most memorable of which was her
voice acting role as the elderly Mrs
hogenson whom Bob par helps with an
insurance claim in The Incredibles I'm
on a fixed income sincere remained
active on television and local theater
into her ninth decade and died of
natural causes at the age of 93 on April
3rd 2013 though some critics were not
impressed by the rocky horle show the
season 2 tribute to Richard O'Brien's
enduring cult musical fans of the 1975
film version were undoubtedly happy to
see two of its stars appear in minor
roles Barry Boswick who played Brad in
The Rocky Horror Picture Show and
meatloaf who played Eddie in both the
film and the original Broadway
production featur as managers of a local
news station who plot with Sue Sylvester
to produce an expose on the school Play
Born Marvin Le a day singer Meatloaf
enjoyed chart's success in three
different decades as well as a second
career as an actor his success on the
pop and rock charts was largely anchored
around the bad Out of Hell album Trilogy
some of the hits off these records
include the epically scaled Paradise by
the Dashboard light and the Grammy
winning I'd do anything for love but I
won't do that as an actor Meatloaf's
best known role outside of Rocky Horror
was as Robert Paulson The sympathetic
ex- weightlifter in David Fincher's
Fight Club however he also appeared in
Wayne's World and the sultan sea and
made guest spots on shows like masters
of horror and Elementary After
experiencing several health issues in
the 2000s he died at the age of 74 in
Nashville Tennessee on January 20th 2022
the character Pete snowski presided in
part over the 2010 Western Ohio
sectionals championship season 2's
special education this character played
by veteran actor Mike Hagerty is
probably best known as the man who
announced that the new directions and
the Warblers tied for first place at
that year's competition the Chicago
native and member of its famed improv
troop the Second City Hagerty began
appearing in minor and supporting roles
in both TV and movies in the early 80s a
go-to for overworked and Easily
Aggravated bluecollar types Hagerty
played cops truck drivers salesmen and
furniture movers on classic sitcoms such
as Married with Children and cheers by
the mid 9s Hagerty had moved up to
supporting roles which included his
best- known small screen characters
grumpy building supervisor Mr triger on
friends and the owner of a vintage
clothing store who budded heads with
Kramer and Seinfeld haerty remained
active well into the New Millennium with
recurring roles in Lucky Louie and
Brooklyn 99 what the hell's going on
around here fire extinguisher roller
chair Derby okay he also co-starred in
the HBO Comedy somebody somewhere teamz
reported that after completing the
latter Show's first season Hagerty
experienced a seizure due to an adverse
reaction antibiotics and lapsed into a
coma the 67-year-old died at Los
Angeles's Cedar Sinai Medical Center on
May 5th 2022 singer and actress Olivia
Newton John parodied her own squeaky
clean image and two appearances on Glee
in season 1's bad reputation she helped
repair the Damage Done to Sue Sylvester
status and dignity after a bootleg video
of her performing Newton John's physical
was leaked to the internet to help Sue
save face Newton John appeared alongside
her in an almost exact duplicate of the
song's original campy music video she
later returned that same season for
journey to Regionals in which she played
a self-centered judge for the new
directions performance at the
competition born in England but raised
in Australia Newton John enjoyed
considerable success in two mediums
throughout the 1970s and 1980s as a
singer she earned 15 top 10 singles on
Billboard's Hot 100 chart including five
number one hits like I honestly love you
and physical in addition to topping the
charts she also earned 12 Grammy
nominations in four wins Newton John's
success as a singer also led to an
acting career that included the
Staggering box office hit Greece which
also generated three top 10 hits and
Xanadu diagnosed with breast cancer in
1992 Newton John became a tireless
advocate for research and treatment the
disease returned in 2017 and
metastasized to her back and Bones
Newton John died at the age of 73 at her
home in the Santa inz Valley in
California on August 8th 2022 Emmy
winning comic actor Tim Conway joined
fellow performing vets Billy D Williams
and Jun squib for season 5's old dog new
tricks the episode which was penned by
cast m M Chris kulur gave its three
guest stars a few moments to shine as
residents at a home for retired actors
who are producing a stage version of
Peter Pan Conway began in Regional
television in the late 1950s before
earning his first break on the Steve
Allen Show a co-starring role on male's
Navy led to several attempts to craft
the TV series around him but Conway
always seemed to Fair best as a
supporting player he was a hilarious
improviser who frequently reduced his
castmates on the Carol Bernett show to
hysterics and teamed with another
Peerless TV comic Don knots in a string
of 70s features for Walt Disney Pictures
Conway was also an in demand guest star
on numerous series like coach and 30
Rock for which he won two additional Mas
he was also a popular voiceover actor
for animated projects most notably
voicing Barnacle Boy in SpongeBob
SquarePants in 2018 Conway was diagnosed
with dementia due to normal pressure
hydris a condition that causes cerebral
spinal fluid to build up in the brain he
died from complications from the
condition at the age of 85 in Los
Angeles on May 14th 2019 best known as
the Creator writer and host of The Long
running Bravo and ation series inside
the actor Studio James Lipton appeared
on Glee's season 3 finale goodbye the
episode which concerned the graduation
of eight glee club members saw a fin
audition for Lipton in order to win a
spot at the prestigious actor Studio
that same year Lipton also interviewed
several Glee cast members and co-creator
Ryan Murphy on an episode of the actor
Studio series inside the actor Studio
was the product of lipton's work as the
dean of the actor Studio drama school a
graduate program for actors that United
the actor studio with New York's new
school University as part of its
curriculum lied recorded interviews with
actors directors and writers about their
crafts these interviews began airing on
Bravo in 1994 and the show's success
vaulted lipped in into pop culture
stardom the host soon parlayed his
success into appearances most often as
himself in series like The Simpsons and
Saturday Night Live livon was also an
actor himself for a Time beginning his
career in radio during the 1940s and
making appearances on Broadway and
television during the 1950s he segued
into writing for television series like
The Guiding Light and specials for
comedian Bob Hope as well as several
novels and Broadway musicals he remained
with the inside the actor studio until
2018 earning 18 Emmy nominations during
the show's 24-year run Lipton died of
bladder cancer at the age of 93 on March
2nd 2020 if you or someone you know may
be the victim of child abuse please
contact the childel National child abuse
hotline at 1 18004 a child 1 1800 422
4453 or contact their live chat
services